foreign
hey there friends so it appears that DC
has finally decided to warm up so I
thought it'd be a good opportunity to
head outside and teach y'all a little
bit about a kind of obscure way to
engage in plane breaking that has
actually been around for years but I'm
just now giving a name Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today we are
talking about benefiting not just your
brains but also your planes ah gotcha
huh but before we dive in let's give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for support supporting my
channel my work and my mission
so somehow this week both spring and
summer came for DC and we climbed into
the 80s which thankfully it appears that
we are staying there at least for the
present
which I actually got inspired by that to
head down to the National Mall and that
was where I first attempted to shoot
this video
but unfortunately uh I forgot to connect
the mic properly so I came away from
that video shoot with no usable audio
but I did come back with some great
b-roll so at least you get some good
shots of the Capitol building in there
right but that's neither here nor there
because we are here to talk about plane
breaking specifically this is an aspect
of poi spinning that involves switching
back and forth between different plane
orientations with our POI generally with
the aid of what we would call a zero
point zero points or moments when we get
the POI to completely stop moving and
they actually make for a great way to
switch the planes that we are spinning
in specifically because once we do a
zero point it means that with zero
momentum to work with the POI can be
redirected any way we want it to now I
first became acquainted with plane
breaking way back in like 2009 or 2010.
my first year at fire drums and facts
and that first year at fire drums I
encountered a British POI spinner who
went by the name G and G absolutely blew
away everybody at the event with his
Innovative approach to switching planes
by using stalls and of course his
approach has now become kind of the
default Way by which we do this within
the Paradigm that he outlined we
basically have two primary tools with
which we can change the planes of the
POI from being vertical planes to being
horizontal planes the first of these
methods is to think of the tips of
flower petals as being the same thing as
stalls and namely you can switch back
and forth between horizontal and
vertical flowers anytime you hit the tip
of a flower petal
[Music]
the second is to actually use a pendulum
in vertical planes and use that to
switch into a horizontal flower this is
actually the method that I first used to
teach myself how to do this form of
plane breaking and I still think that
it's a great exercise for doing this
thank you
[Music]
but there's also a third method and as
it turns out we've known about it almost
as long as those first two methods so
years ago I went to a flow Festival that
met in the Los Angeles area and
afterwards I was hanging out and doing a
little spin jam with Ronan McLaughlin
Kate McCoy and I'm pretty sure that g
was there too and no I don't have any
footage of this regrettably I was so
focused on being in it that I forgot to
whip out my camera of all things but
there was an odd curiosity that we
discovered that day see the theory
behind most of those other types of
plane breaks is you're using a zero
point that is a moment when the POI
loses all of its momentum so you can
redirect it
but what we discovered in the course of
that spin Jam was that there is also a
way that you can redirect that momentum
while the POI is moving you don't need
to stop it now we didn't think to name
this phenomenon at the time we just
thought it was kind of a strange
curiosity because it really flew in the
face of what we believed that we knew
about plane breaking
but it's something that in retrospect
looking back on it I'm realizing is now
a Cornerstone to how I engage in plane
breaking the technique itself is
basically centered around taking a
moment when the POI is spinning in one
plane and with a quick snap of the wrist
you can get it moving in a completely
different plane without stopping it from
moving in the original plane and because
we neglected to give this technique a
name at the time I'm coming up with a
name for it now and that name is
plane snaps now granted this is not the
most imaginative name for a POI trick
but I think that it works on a couple
levels number one it's pretty simple
number two I think it's Snappy yes pun
intended and number three I think it
suggests by its very name what exactly
it entails so with this in mind I
started taking a look at my own flow and
I was surprised by the number of ways
that plane snaps manifest in how I do my
own plane breaking so so I want to share
a few of those with you all in case it
might inspire you to find your own
approaches to doing this first and
foremost there are the methods that I
originally learned in that little spin
jam with G and Ronan namely taking both
extensions as well as pendulums and
doing really rapid clean breaks out of
them still to this day I think that this
is one of the most beautiful and
eye-catching ways that we can engage in
this
in addition there's also performing
plane snaps out of the tips of anti-spin
flowers at first blush this might look a
lot like the plane breaking that g first
showed us back in the day but the
crucial difference here is that I'm not
going from anti-spin to anti-spin going
from anti-spin to extension or in spin
this is actually such a common element
of my POI dance style that now I can't
unsee it
[Music]
and of course there's this fun technique
where I switch into horizontal Buzz saws
off of a variety of different kinds of
stalls a lot of people have asked me how
we get these super clean horizontal
plane transitions in these positions and
well this is how
[Music]
so these are literally just the first
three that popped up off the top of my
head as I was thinking about this
particular technique and I'm sure that
there are countless more that I will now
that I'm looking for it be able to see
in my own spinning so with all that in
mind I thought I would give you all a
sampling of a whole bunch of different
plane breaking using a variety of
different techniques including these
plane snaps and the older versions that
use zero points so check that out
foreign
[Music]
awesome so let me know what are your
thoughts on this particular POI
technique do you like my name for it was
there already a name out there that I
just didn't know about leave me a
comment and let me know please be sure
to like comment share and subscribe to
keep the conversation going to help
people find this video and of course to
help my channel grow
foreign
would not be possible without the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very generous support and
if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter but you'd like to
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out of my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you and despite this turning out
to only partially be a video of me going
out for a field trip in DC if you'd like
to see other videos that genuinely are
me going out for a field trip in DC I
will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of those down in the
description as well as up here on screen
on YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look-see as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out to flow today and see
you with a new video real soon peace